I'm just going to have the last word and
he's also gonna have the first word
after me I don't know about a last word
I feeling a bit an impostor with the
headteacher label because I'm being the
head teacher for all of 11 weeks what a
lot of that always wasn't but anyway um
two minutes only enough time to say one
thing really which to add a Norman great
advice I guess I just say be passionate
about mathematics be passionate for your
subject you know there's a difference
between maths teachers and
mathematicians right there's math
teachers and get up and here's how to do
XYZ and so on and there are
mathematicians and they get up in their
life
look iteration the volume of the sphere
seriously just just watch them see the
4/3 PI R cubed coming out and their
brains just explode
be excited about that and communicate
that to your students I lost count of
the number of times people said oh sure
well I'm in your classroom I feel like
doing mathematics what do you feel like
in the other classroom I think it's
because sadly sometimes we get busy with
ports and parents get us down or you
know you're just busy and it's a long
term just sick and tired just remember
for these kids they excused mathematics
through one lens so so give them
something that's worth experiencing
because you know something